you know i was um
i was looking at some drawings of uh
native americans and
you know i realized i couldn't even
it's sad to admit but i couldn't even be
native american
and no offense to anybody that's an n a
no offense to you guys
i love your work i've seen you know most
of what i've seen is drawings but
you know i love but i love y'all's work
and i mean that you know
i love all you know i respect native
americans
um if i you know i was born too late in
the world
if i was born earlier i probably would
have
you know try to smooth things over a
little bit better whenever
you know you guys kind of had the
falling out with the
with some of the whites to be honest
i would have said hey hey you know
let's figure this out guys but
i think both of you guys are kind of
high tempered it seems like
if i'm really honest if i look back in
some of the drawings it seems
you know uh
oh excuse me a little belt or burp i
don't know which one is which
oh they're both disgusting i feel like
air is just kind of just raping my
throat every time it happens
oh i hate that
but um but yeah again i want to
apologize to any
you know i know we have some native
american listeners some
nals basically or something you know we
know what i'm talking about
we have us we have some native american
listeners i have native american in me
okay i probably got half a pint okay i
probably got half a pint i probably got
six teaspoons of chippewa or something
daddy's got it in them
i can feel it sometimes in the middle of
the night
you know i'll hear something outside
i'll hear something about 40 paces away
and i don't use the term paces very
often so that's right then when i know
that i say odess
that's a very select ounce or two of me
that's listening
there and that's that native american in
me
but yeah i want to apologize to native
americans on behalf of kind of some of
the ways stuff went down
you know it's uh it was just kind of a
wild time i think
and you know you can't win them all i
guess
you know i don't know what to how do we
shake
you know merge the past in the future so
i don't know
i don't even know what i'm talking about
what was i talking about uh
[Music]
[ __ ] i don't even know man
oh my god dude i had what a week
what a weekend what i mean what uh
my weekend was great it was my weekend
was tough um
it was it was everything
you know it was everything weekend it
was like one of those bagels that have
ever you know
everything on it it just looks like your
spice rack just took a
you know took some bread and just did a
damn gang bang on it
but um
but yeah so you know we do what we can
uh and um
yeah let's look let's crack into the
episode
i think that's the way to do it and uh
and i'll just share more you know
just try and share about what's going on
um
yeah you know i need help sometimes i
need some help
sometimes i need some help so
you know when and it's hard to say that
it's hard to say that i need some help
sometimes and sometimes i do uh let's
get into this episode here we go
you always are the one who
keeps together you always are the one
who knows just what we need
you always are the one who stays home
with the baby
you gonna be the one who stays right
here with me
well i've been working fingers down
[Music]
hard as i can just find some
why
[Music]
this is our time
and that right there that's uh grady
spencer and the work
and they're hitting you with that hot
tune right there
they're upgrading your ear stems right
there with that hot tune
grady spencer and the work our time is
that
song that listening piece
and ah and we're here we're here we're
here we're moving in it's october
you know we're moving in and we're
moving forward and
you know i had a tough weekend man i you
know i don't want to you know
i've just had a tough i i've just had a
tough time recently
um and i don't like to
you know it's hard for me sometimes with
uh
to not to to share how i feel and not
sound like i am complaining
or like i ha i'm not or just having a
lot of self-pity
um and it's it's it's hard for me to do
you know it's hard
you know i think it's become tougher
when i was on this podcast to talk to us
about how i feel because
i i don't
i don't want to
i don't want to complain and i don't
want to be seen as a complainer
um and you know it's you know it's
interesting
you know as my career has gone on over
the past few years and
has gotten busier uh
you know i start to feel like oh well
nobody wants to hear what your problems
are
if they think that your
life is
good or that you you know here i am
getting to live out
my dreams
and so to then still come back and have
a
have complaints have uncomfort
uh that stuff sounds i don't know it's
just hard it's hard to share it's hard
to
um it's scary it's scary to share
because i'm like well
you know who's who nobody wants to
listen to somebody complain that
that has you know that has uh
that's like living their dream it just
doesn't
so it's just been tough man i just have
not been feeling that good i think
especially about the past six or nine
months and
i try to talk about it sometimes but i
don't know what's going on
you know i don't know what's going on um
and uh and so you know you just keep
showing up and
you know i had i just had a moment this
past week and
uh while i was getting a drink the other
night i was gonna drink and
you know i don't know if i have a
drinking problem i know that i don't do
well when once i get hold of cocaine
i don't do super great
you know i do not do super great if i am
doing cocaine
so the other day you know i had the
shows up in new jersey with trevor
wallace and he's amazing and it was
great and francis ellis beautiful fella
tall fella too i mean tall white i mean
if somebody did something to the native
americans i'm gonna
it was somebody he you know probably
somebody he knew or in his
gene pool you know if you drink a
a half cup of out of his gene pool you
could definitely taste a couple native
americans
you know losing their land i'll say that
um but one of the smartest
and uh and hardest working guys
is francis ellis no shortcuts with that
felon and so beautiful to you know just
to see him and spend time with him and
and
trevor's and trevor's uh you know i i
just i respect both those guys so much
and so i was
i was happy to be out there with them
and the first show was amazing it was
one of my favorite shows ever
uh out there in um in new jersey
in the state of new jersey up there in
northeastern america
and then the second show was
it was it was good it just it was all
over the place kind of
you ever look for something you just
can't find it it was kind of like that a
little
um and that's my perception as well
you may have been sitting there and had
a great time but uh
but you know i like it to be just you
know
i'll always want it to be perfect for
everybody um
and so anyway i think everybody did have
a great time but but anyway those just
that's just kind of how i felt about
them
um but the day was just that day was
just rough and i'd
you know i'd been uh i went to the
i went to the airport in the morning
from nashville and i
flew to the wrong airport in in new york
and i flew into laguardia
and that's about an hour and a half away
from the venue
whereas um
newark was about 40 minutes from the
venue so just e it would have been a lot
easier so i flew into the wrong
airport and i had to get an uber
so i took an uber an hour and whatever
it was
hour and 40 minutes hour and 20 minutes
it was a it was a waste
uh and i was just stressed out man
you know i just really you know i've
been trying not to drink for a while
and i just kind of decided in my head
you know man i'm i'm in a drink i'm
going to drink when i get to this hotel
i'm just going to have myself a damn
drink
you know and i don't think and i i've
never been the kind of person to just
drink and drink and drink
i don't like that i don't like hell i
don't like having to get up and go pee
so i i don't want to have a bunch of
drinks
you know but the reason i don't drink is
because i just get worried that then if
i get approached with
cocaine you know where that dust that
jack jack
then i'm gonna be out there son i'll be
out in your garden
you know i'll be out there in your
recycling bin with a couple of raccoons
baby
doing dirty baby doing dirty works
that's where my mind kind of goes and
but i just decided man
you know i got this i got a hotel room
with this place called oyster point
hotel
because they have the place is kind of
it's a little bit of it's kind of shitty
and i like that it's kind of nice though
it's like shitty nice you know
it's like that um
like you ever been to a funeral but they
got uh like a thing of mints right by
the coffin
like a little snack bowl or whatever
right by the call like a little
oh yeah you know you know uh
you know keith is dead but also
you know have a mint that kind of place
so i
it just had that kind of vibe and um
anyway i get there and i thought in my
head well the whole time i'm riding
there i'm just furious and the guy
oh the uber driver
kept telling me he had asthma and about
his
journey with asthma
dude we got bigger
fish to fry in the world right now than
somebody having
an asthma journey bro
maybe if you can't breathe well maybe
god don't
want you around yeah have you thought
about that huh puff puff
maybe if you can't take a hit off the
world
correctly maybe the lord's looking for
you
so anyway an hour and a half i listen to
you know captain [ __ ] camp puff
talk about his 65 years dude with 65
65 years of lung issues and he had
crosses hanging
everywhere in the uber he had
i mean there was a cross there was
there's a cross here
you know at one point i reached behind
my ear and i pulled out a cross like he
had there was
i don't know if this guy lives if he had
a vampire as an ex-wife i don't know
what's going on
but the lord i mean i guess the lord was
with us
for sure it was an uber pool because
they had there's no way there weren't a
couple of straight-up disciples in the
trunk
so i'm riding with this dude captain
asthma and uh
and he kept pulling oh this was the
worst part
and i'm just thinking oh god
um and i made it up the black belt oh
god
i was in taekwondo for many years as a
as a
teen okay well good um
so what i'm saying is this that uh so
i've been thinking about i was thinking
about drinking i was thinking about
drinking i'm thinking okay when i get to
this hotel
they have a nice restaurant there that's
one thing it's just
i really love it place that have a nice
restaurant nice place to eat you're
sitting looking right out the water
beautiful so you could be eating a fish
and taste right where it came from
you could be eating a fish right there
having you a little bit of pond a pond
carp or whatever
you know north african pond carp or
something you gutting down some of that
and you'll see its family member swim
right up by the window and look at you
just hit you with that one eye you know
hey that's my dad
you know
and so i guess i kept romanticizing in
my head okay i'm gonna sit there i'm
gonna have me some food i'm gonna have
me some drinks
uh and i'm just gonna relax
man um and so you know
anyway we go oh the guy kept having to
pull over to breathe
fresh air
the guy kept having to pull over to
breathe
fresh air in new jersey
off the turnpike there ain't no fresh
air
there ain't no fresh air about a
turnpike dude
bring a bag of air from somewhere else
fill up a balloon from damn kansas or
something
and get that thing you know get that
thing trucked in or trained in
oh
so we pull over this is the second time
we pulled over to get fresh air in
i'm not sure where it was some little
town
uh and a guy
comes up to the car we stop it's
literally like we have to stop for a
minute
and he will the first time he put his
head out the window and the second time
he got out of the
vehicle to breathe this is
this and i'm just i'm like
it's already this is a 200 uber
and it was a small car
okay it was small
and some of you guys are thinking well
theo you know you've made some money why
don't you get a nice get somebody
i agree but that's just not who i am i
don't that's not
i don't like to get i try to be thrifty
you know that's just who i am i don't
you know that's just who i am it's just
in my nature
you know sometimes i don't want to
sometimes i don't want to give myself
you know the creature comforts i don't
want to take care of myself like that
and i probably should
because then i just get more stressed so
anyway dude we're out there and a
brother i'll be honest straight up
brother urban brother whatever however
you want to term it
you know um comes up
and starts asking if we want to buy some
drugs
um and the asthma guy the
uh
the driver starts asking me
like it kind of directs him towards me
like i don't [ __ ]
like what is going on here i don't i the
guy i
i'm i am i'm i'm paying to be on this
shh this shitty
adventure with freaking billy bad
lungs up here who can't handle the world
and now i gotta tell i don't want any
drugs that dudes
starts looking at two of the crosses if
they're for sale like dog we ain't doing
this [ __ ] right now
like i'm just you know what y'all doing
around here
we're here because he this guy
this guy wants some [ __ ] this guy
wants some fresh air
by this railroad tracks and by these
walgreens
that's why we're here that's why we're
here
and just nobody wants to believe you bro
when you're out there like that
so i'm just fear and i'm just like i
can't wait to drink now i'm gonna drink
gasoline i'm thinking about i'm thinking
i'm gonna drink ethanol i'm gonna drink
i am going to have someone else do a two
two three four five eight balls
a 40 ball i'm have somebody do at least
a 32 ball of cocaine then i'm gonna
drink their blood that's where i'm at
that's where i'm at i'm not doing super
well
so we get rid of old dude
you know and uh and we hit the we hit
the road and it's the last time
and um finally we get to the hotel and
the lady says where are you coming from
and i said uh just flew in from
tennessee
and she goes well
unfortunately since you flew in through
a high risk state
you uh you can't access any of our
communal areas which means the
restaurant
uh and the gym um
she goes however we are gonna open the
gym after midnight if you if you wanted
to get into there
and i'm like i don't know what
you know what that's not that's that's
not a real
moment um but okay uh
so anyway so now i'm just furious man
because the one reason i wanted to stay
at this place
you know in this expensive place it's
300 bucks a night you know when they got
the toilet in there like the fraternity
house when the one with the silver
handle out the side you know where you
pull that little
like it's like a straight handle like oh
you can see the plumbing coming out of
the back
like it's a it was really nice
30 years ago but the nice thing there is
though there's the restaurant
and the staff too nothing about the
people
[Music]
um so anyway man uh
so now i'm angry i'm angry man
and i've been angry man i've been angry
for months and i just i'm angry and i
said well kelsey you know
that was her name i said kelsey i
wouldn't do that to you
i said we'll catch you at least
like you know she goes you can order
room service
and i was like but the reason i even
picked this hotel
was because i wanted to eat in the
restaurant
and i wanted to sit in there and have a
drink that's what i wanted
i'd romanticize this i want to sit in
there and i want to have a damn
d-r-i-n-k okay
and i just rode two hours with captain
can't inhale over here
this beleaguered senior citizen i don't
i mean that guy
there's no way that guy's still alive i
mean this guy was on his last
lung bro so anyway
anyway she said i'm sorry you can't go
in there
you can we'll have food we can have food
delivered to your room so i was upset
and i went up to my room
um and then i ordered food in my room i
had like
i had about 50 minutes till i had to be
at the venue
and i ordered the food in my room uh
and i prayed man honestly i mean i just
hit my knees and prayed i just said you
know god i need some help man
you know i'm just so angry and i don't
know why
and um
and i got in the shower and and
uh and then the guy brought my food up
and the drink i'd ordered a jack and
diet
and it wasn't the drink really that i
wanted but i just
i don't know that's what that's what i
ordered and
and and
there was something about the fact that
i kind of romanticized the idea i'm
going to drink but i'm going to drink
down in this nice restaurant it's going
to be you know this love i'm going to be
able to look out at the water it's going
to be cool i'll make the fish
his family's gonna swim by it's gonna be
kind of like one like a part of the
godfather a little bit
it's gonna be interesting and instead uh
the fact that i couldn't have the drink
there in that place like once it got to
my room i just didn't want it
and so i said well if i'm still feeling
bad later i'll have it and um
and i ate my food and went to the shows
and uh and that was that
so i mean i only tell that story just
because you know
i'm trying not to drink
and sometimes it's really hard
and that was one that was just one of
those times i mean
and i don't talk about it that much on
here i like to keep that kind of stuff
sometimes
separate because i don't want to have to
like every week report
on how i'm doing with being sober or
feel like i have to
uh you know because it's my own journey
um but it was interesting that once
it was interesting because then i got
this perspective that oh well god's
doing for me what i can't do for myself
because
if that if they would have allowed me to
go into that restaurant
i wasn't even gonna put my bags in my
room i was gonna go sit in there i
hadn't eaten all day i was gonna go sit
in there
i had four cookies on the plane but i
was gonna go
sit in there and uh
i think
and now i i just hear here's what i'm
saying is i i realized at that moment i
was like oh i didn't
that if i would if i if i would have
been able to go in
just right into the restaurant i wasn't
even take my bags to my room
if i would have been able to go right to
the restaurant i was just gonna go sit
in there and order a drink
and um and i just you know i'm just
trying not to
and i just i guess i want to tell that
story just
i don't know i think you know
i think god was doing for me what i
can't do for myself
you know he's he he and
and at first it was made me so angry but
then i'm like man if i would have
if that restaurant would have allowed me
in then i would have drank
you know i would have drank and
anyway i know you know that doesn't
matter to some people but when you're
trying not to
um and you just got so much anger built
up and you don't even know why
uh it just gets i don't know it gets
heavy sometimes
elephants are a good sound it just
um
yeah i i don't know and so yeah the
drink just sat there
and it melted and and i don't know i'm
not saying that i won't that i'm not
gonna drink sometime i don't know what
i'm going to do but
i just got to get some help i just got
to start feeling better
and i'm not trying to complain um
but i just don't feel i don't feel
good
you know and i i don't feel good and i
want to i want to enjoy my life
you know i want to be able to enjoy my
life
and be of service to other people and
and i'm just having a tough time doing
that right now
because i don't feel great so
i'm not trying to complain i'm not
trying to have self-pity i'm trying to
take action uh
you know i'm trying to see a new
therapist um
i'm looking into getting a new sponsor
uh through 12-step
stuff and um
but yeah i don't know i just i just
wanted to kind of tell some of that
story and uh
and then i want to let you guys know
that it has been reported that americans
are overpaying
on car insurance by over 21
billion dollars can you believe that
i'm not shocked actually car insurance
is is expensive and
uh man i mean it's expensive dude
i've been in maybe four or five wrecks
and mine is like 200 a month dude
insane you know that's crazy i'd rather
just keep that money
no i shouldn't i no never mind that
doesn't make any sense but
but anyway when you're searching for a
better deal it can take hours and
typically results in a barrage of
unwanted spam calls that's the worst
you know you you fill out a form and
next you know you're getting a thousand
calls and people hitting you up until
now
the zebra.com the zebra is the nation's
leading car insurance comparison site
because it's the only place you can
compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less who doesn't want that
name 40 people that don't want that you
just answer a few questions on a simple
fast form and they'll find you the best
rates and coverage
in your state techcrunch calls
the zebra kayak for auto insurance
the best part is that it's completely
free you can save up to six hundred and
seventy dollars a year
using the zebra.com so to find out how
much you can save on car insurance
and home insurance go today and start
saving at
the zebra.com t-h-e-o
that's the zebra dot c-o-m
slash t-h-e-o spelled t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot slash theo
so go find out go find out how much you
can save get back out on the road
and have the best coverage you can for
the best price
on auto and home insurance the zebra.com
theo
support the podcast
i'll also let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
and it's probably something i need right
now you know
it probably wouldn't even be a bad idea
for me to use better help
um and maybe i will
you know maybe i will you know i'm
actually going to uh
try an appointment with a therapist that
i've had before
um and uh and then looking uh
if that's not what i'm feeling then
maybe looking at getting a new one but i
just have to take action
you know that's what i have to do and
i'm not ashamed to admit it man i want
to be i want to
i want to enjoy my life you know
you know i'm living out some of my
dreams and i'm not
and i'm not enjoying it and i'm just not
enjoying me i'm not enjoying being
human and i think that there's more out
there for me
so betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 24 hours
now it's not a crisis line okay it's
self-help now it's not a crisis line
okay it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done
securely online you know if you're
living in an area where
the counselor maybe also does the snow
cones
you can't you go over there and you say
hey you know let me get a medium grape
and also you know i've been jerking off
and i you know before work and they're
like well
you know maybe they don't you know they
say well you just need the small grape
then you have a little too much
a little too much grape in you but
that's the thing you don't know if it's
a small town that might be the scenario
but that's why they got better options
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
the service is available online for
clients worldwide
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
as you do with traditional therapy
elephants are a good sound
better help is committed to facil
facilitating great therapeutic matches
and they want you to start living a
happier life today visit betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over half a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for tpw
listeners get 10
off with your first month at
betterhelp.com
theo that's betterhelp.com theo
um yeah a good intro song there by grady
spencer and the work
from their album celebrate and that song
is called our time
but yeah i just haven't been feeling
good
you know i just have been feeling a lot
of stress and i don't know
and i just been feeling angry
and
and i almost you know i almost don't
want to say that
uh i almost don't you know
i don't because i'm scared i guess
i'm scared of what people are gonna
think i'm scared of what you're gonna
think
um
but i don't feel that great and i don't
feel that great enough of the time where
it's a
you know it's a recur it's a it's
something that i have to just i gotta do
more
[Music]
um
you know so so i'm i'm gonna try i mean
i did some things today you know i went
for a run in the middle of the day i
didn't want to
but i did it um
i'm getting my blood work done just
check to make sure that everything's
okay inside of me to make sure you know
just staying on top of that um
you know i'm gonna go to an aaa meeting
later today and just uh
i spoke to some of my you know 12 step
friends on the phone and and i think
some of it is just
too much of me you know a lot of my life
has you know
um you know i think
some something that will help me is
doing stuff for other people
so i need to try and lean into that a
little bit more um
but i'm just tired i feel every day like
i'm fighting something and i don't know
what it is
and i feel every day like i'm like like
i'm just constantly just
pushing trying to i don't even know what
i'm pushing or what i'm pushing against
um
uh i'm trying to explain it but i
thought i'm trying to
like feel it and share it at the same
time
um and i'm not trying to have self-pity
on myself i'm trying to be
active you know i used to get bummed out
for years and i would just lay
lay in bed man be be sad and sleep
definitely helps
but i can't do that forever you know i
have to take action in my life i have
friends and
people that need me and
and i want to be healthy so i can
you know i feel like i feel like god
wants me to be able to be a part of
helping people or being a part of
people's lives
you know i want to be a part of that
river of like comfort in the world and
river of like healthiness and stuff and
and i just can't be a part of it if i'm
not feeling good myself so
anyway i'm not gonna try and dwell on it
too much but it was just amazing that
man i wanted that drink man and that
just the simple thing that that lady
said the restaurant is not open to you
and i and i was so angry but really
that was a higher power saying hey
[Music]
you know let me do for you what you
can't do for yourself right now and
and i did feel like that was pretty
powerful
um so
oh
but yeah i talked a little bit uh here
let's get in here let's take a call or
two here we go
let me shut up i just sometimes on this
podcast even i feel so bad just talking
all the time
because it's always me you know um
it's always me hey theo this is
johnny from new jersey what's up johnny
from jersey baby
and no no no relation to jersey mike's
over there and they got the sweaty meat
they got the meat that seemed glossy on
the outside
like somebody you know parked a a 84
chevrolet over to meet for half an hour
and left it running
and now it's got that slick look on it
gang um
just left this show it was a great time
um i think you're doing good making
people laugh during these hard rough
times
i just want to say keep it up and we all
support you here we had a blast over
there we were
crying laughing and uh
we'll always uh support you brother so
gang gang
man thank you dude that was real timely
and i appreciate it man
yeah i think sometimes i just put all
this pressure maybe on myself i don't
know like if if i don't do something
right the right way that
that people aren't gonna care anymore
and so then it makes me kind of i think
afraid to like do anything
you know if i'm not the right amount of
funny or the right amount of serious or
the right i just
you know i put this impossible
and i don't even know if i do it
consciously that's the thing it's not
like choices i'm making it's like
you know i think probably when i was
young i felt like if i didn't behave a
certain way that people weren't going to
care about me
that like the care that i received from
people
was directly correlated to how i behaved
and i was only going to be cared about
if i behaved an exact way
and i could never figure out what that
way was
so i think you know sometimes probably
in my life that's why
you know i've always probably a lot of
me has been searching you know this
searching for some
how do i crack this code how do i get
this
how do i what numbers you have to line
up correctly
to get the care that i need you know um
but yeah i think um
you know and i was never good at saying
when i needed help
i was never good at saying hey i need
help you know i
and it's so funny because even as a
child you know i was a loud man i was
always saying
something
but it was all like
it was all just hot air man the thing i
needed to say was just
then i need i i need i need some help
you know i need somebody
i need to feel that somebody cares about
me
you know that's what i needed it when i
was young
um but i had that emotional asthma man
when you think about i had that
emotional asthma i just
because i just didn't know i just didn't
know i didn't know what was going on
um and i'm not trying to sound whiny you
know i know i keep
saying that but i'm not like
you know oh man nothing's ever going to
be good
i'm not i'm not feeling that way i'm
just trying to feel
what feelings are inside of me so i can
so i can take some action um
and some days man i just it's hard to be
funny sometimes some days it's hard to
just
it's hard man it's just like i got in
here today and i was like [ __ ] what am i
gonna do
you know but then i get this voicemail
right here um
i just want to say keep it up and we all
support you here we had a blast
over there we were crying laughing and
uh we'll always uh support you brother
so gang gang
you know and that changes the script in
me because then then i hear oh we'll
always support you
you know we'll always support you um
and it's just something you know i think
it's something that you you got to tell
your kids when they're young is that
you know just that you love them no
matter what they're doing no matter what
like no matter what
because i always felt like everything
every
next step of my comfort was dependent
upon
how i was behaving at that second at
that moment
it was all so dependent upon like how
whenever my mom got home how was she
feeling
you know it didn't matter how i was
feeling however she was feeling then
that's how
the night was gonna go
you know a lot of there just wasn't room
for my feelings
um
and so a lot of times i think when i was
young i just didn't have them
and so then that's why i have more of
them now sometimes because i think
you know feelings are they're patient
they're real real patient but at some
point they trying to leave the bus
station
so i think some of them they just i have
them later on and i have them now and
um
yeah i don't know i'm just trying to
think out loud and
you know because a lot of people have
said to me over the years that you know
you know theo i like
when you share what's going on with you
because sometimes you say stuff that i i
can feel
and uh and you guys do it to me
you know like this guy right here hard
rough times
um i just want to say keep it up and we
all support you here
we had a blast over there we were crying
laughing
and uh we'll always uh support you
brother
so gang gang
yes you know it's just we got a good
group of support here and
i think it's cool man but um thank you
again for the nice message man i really
yeah and i'm yeah i don't i don't know
why you know this episode just whatever
it is man i'm tired i'm
just [ __ ] tired i'm tired of having
to like uh
sometimes not just be able to be how i
want to be
and i know that you guys didn't make it
that way i know that sometimes i've made
it that way in my own head
i know that sometimes just the past like
you know life
this work got busier the past year and a
half
um you know i was sitting yesterday
talking to somebody and telling that i
went to
tour in europe and man i i hardly have
any
recollection of it
i guess cry you know i hardly have it
just
things were just just things just fast
just fast just
you know just a lot um and it's a
blessing and that's not what i'm saying
i'm just saying
that uh that for a guy like me that
feels a lot of stuff it's a
lot it's a lot sometimes um
but the best part man i will say the
best part it was such a gift man when i
showed up over to the show i did i
didn't drink i felt so good about myself
i said man how did i don't know how you
did it
you know when i called a friend when i
was in the car and i even told him on
the way there i said hey man this
if this uber driver gets back in the car
soon or if he doesn't i don't know but
i'm drinking
you know and he sent me a link to some
video and it was some
i don't even know some of them baseball
thing i don't know it was the worst
thing ever but
but just the fact that i broke up that
that the thought in my head
it just kind of gave weaken that power
and then i got to the place and they
said oh we can't go in a nice restaurant
you gotta eat up in your room by the
fraternity toilet
said damn i mean even this [ __ ] this
place was old bro they had old shows on
television like what the [ __ ] dog
dude i turned on golden girls a couple
all all of them were still alive
on the show that's how this thing was
old
um there was a george bush senior
advertise like vote for george bush
senior
one of the commercials like this
everything in there was old
it was and i was angry
but that place has an amazing restaurant
and i got up to my room and here was the
crazy part that my room wasn't even
facing like the water it was just facing
like the parking lot
and i'm like uh if this good thing it's
only four story i'd jump out the damn
window right now
good thing it's only four stories and
that's concrete looks i could handle
that it was not concrete it was uh
asphalt i could live off four stories in
asphalt i'll live
you can ask any gypsy that i'll live
there dude kushner
but if i go four stories on the concrete
i'm probably not gonna
i'm not surviving oh shout out to the
dude too that came out to the late show
in the wheelchair man
and he had in enable legs his legs was
enabled by a um
dirt bike a dirt bike and
just did him dirty and man he had such a
great attitude man it
he had such a great attitude man i
really i just
i really i you know almost wanted to
just cut off one of my damn legs and
give it to him
and then me and him could just
three-legged race around the world
together no homo bro
you feel me dog you stay on your side of
the leg i'll stay on my side of the leg
at night
but but anyway
well i guess you couldn't do i guess if
you gave
yes somebody a leg but then i don't know
how that but anyway yeah no homo dude
bro but also dude yeah you know but if
somebody is gay then also
yes homo i don't want anybody to think
that i'm not you know
being cool to gay people or anything so
no homo and yes homo dog
gang [ __ ] um
what else here's someone else that came
and they came out to the show let's take
up more show calls
hey what's up this is steve coming at
you currently from
the highway even into virginia what's up
steve out there on the road baby
and i've driven out on the road now i
like to get me a little bit of caramel
corn when i'm out there driving or
riding brother
onward uh originally from long branch
new jersey
you're actually just uh about five
minutes from my whole
hometown over there in uh blue grotto
oh yeah he's out there about a dog track
and a lot you know you could smell oh
dude you could smell a damn dachshund
from the stage man you could hear the
dog track over there
people betting on a dog and losing a
there's nothing sadder than somebody
gambling on a damn dog
track because the information at least
if it's a horse you can get some
information you can get a little bit of
intel on them
but a damn you know somebody got you
know a walmart
you know somebody got a rottweiler [ __ ]
zoom mix out there and it's supposed to
run in the seventh race
you know what i'm saying but it hasn't
had lunch like you just get weird like
oh yeah
you know peaky blinder or whatever the
dog's name is or something you know he
he hadn't had lunch and that's the kind
of intel you get and you're still
supposed to lay 20 30 on a damn dog
you know i took a date out to the dog
track over there in tucson arizona one
time out there
and she hated me that lady that lady
hated him she was an older lady and i
thought well what does older lady want
to do probably something
you know advanced you know so i thought
gambling
and i took her out there and bet on the
dog bet six dollars on this dog
you know nine dollars on that one trying
to show out a little
and i bet nine and both them [ __ ]
lost and then that [ __ ] left
so you got to take women where they care
or to good stuff but anyway
sorry uh making this about me homer
steve that i missed the show
couldn't go i've been trying to see you
for a couple years now
but uh i'm in the marine corps so uh
you know beauty calls can't be around
but
man i bet you probably had a great show
trying to see you at some point this
year hopefully
even with all this code good stuff going
on but
yeah i've been going through tough times
and relationships and stuff and starting
on my career but
hey man your stuff on this past weekend
and king of this thing
that stuff uh keeps me going man makes
me laugh and
like i said i can't wait to see you on
the show sometime definitely excited for
next special or something
thanks man thanks dude that's sweet of
you to say that man i can
i can feel that you know i can feel you
being genuine and uh
and yeah thank you you know uh uh and we
we do have a new special you know we're
signing a deal with netflix and
it's just paperwork now and um
and to do a special and so that'll be
great for that to come out steve so
you'll be able to see it and share that
with your uh
um your semper fi uh fellas
out there and uh and
you know i think that's pretty cool man
to be in the military i think there's
one thing i admired when i used to go do
some military tours and i hope to do
some again
was just the camaraderie you get to have
to be in a group of people
and to be able to just joke around
and you know i know it's grueling a lot
of the hours you guys have and i know
you're not
where your desired location a lot of
times but
you know it's so often so rare sorry in
life that i find you get to have a group
of people around who enjoy one another
especially right now um
so man i'm really i'm envious in a lot
of ways it just
you be able to have that brotherhood and
just people are just you get to enjoy
people that's
that's a delicacy right now
a lot of people can enjoy people a lot
of people can't
you know people still can't go see their
grandparents or
there's fear around it um
but but be well man and thank you for
the warm message man
and uh and enjoy that enjoy each other
you know enjoy it man that's such a
it's going to be prehistoric human
beings spending time with each other
the way that we're so addicted to
electronica now
let's take another call homework hey
theo
it's um there from trenton new jersey
so i just got home from your show i went
to the seven o'clock show
hey bear and thank you for calling and
that's a unique name for a woman
but that's how they do it in the
northeast you know you got more people
from
britain more people you know you got
that native american meat's kind of
you know kind of defeated by the white
kind of vibe
up there so you'll have a kid named bear
you'll have a kid named uh
you know river branch or whatever um
you know fire but you know fire you love
a kid named
fire like damn where's fire dude i don't
know
he's got the wii you know i so they got
you know you'll have unique names go on
bear down there in ocean port new jersey
and man it was a great great great time
and i really needed it because i just
been going through
a really batch where i went through a
breakup and i went through
drinking way too much and now i'm sober
and i'm on antidepressants but besides
that
it was great except there was this [ __ ]
and she just kept screaming
for no reason and then the last 15
minutes of your set
she just talked [ __ ] about how she was
on your podcast before
now i was on this podcast before
i was and everyone just wanted her to
shut the [ __ ] up
so but besides that you were great
and me and my friends we had a great
time and i really appreciate it and
love you man love you too
thank you very much for that for the
nice message and i think there was one
lady up at the front that was too loud
and she might have been doing drugs i
don't know and she had big titties too
i'll be honest with you two of them
and she had them big old titty man look
like each one of her titties had been
drinking beer
it looked like each one of her titties
could have been on a bowling team in the
90s
you know she had the big old
she had them long branches if you will
baby uh
and she was loud i think a lot of times
a titty will hold a lot of volume
you know so sometimes if you see
somebody with a big titty woman they'll
have earmuffs on or something
but yeah next time i'll do a little bit
better job it's hard for me to gauge
here's the hard thing to gauge from the
stage
if somebody is a heckler or somebody is
being obtuse
are they enjoying themselves
or are they trying to be seen
that's the tough part
because some lady the other night up
front laughed like uh
i had a really really really weird laugh
and i don't know honestly how to handle
that don't
honestly i don't honestly
so it's tough you know it's tough to
know what is a good sound and what isn't
a good sound
elephants are a good sound
it's tough it's you just have to but if
it gets
a little too much that's when i say
something and also the staff is supposed
to do something
but you also don't want to like
interrupt the jokes the second show that
was a drunk guy who was not
he was he needs to be sober you're
probably you sound okay
that guy probably needs to tighten it up
because he just was
the show he made it about him but maybe
not who knows man
but thank you for the warm message you
know and that's the thing it's just like
sometimes i don't want to drink because
i want to be able to be there for
somebody if they're having a tough time
or something i don't i want to be able
to say hey man
i'm here and i'm available and i'm so
i'm of right mind right now so i can be
a part of
i don't know i just feel like it's hard
for my higher power to use me if i
am all [ __ ] up on that gas or whatever
but that's just me some people can do a
bunch of coke
you know and raise a family i'm reading
the my pillow guys book right now
that dude's smoking crack and and making
pillows
so if that ain't i mean that sounds like
community college
so there's ways to do it is what i'm
saying
but but i'm glad y'all came and i'm glad
you laughed and i'll tell you this that
first show i'll put this on anything
i it might have been the best show i've
ever had
man it just you know sometimes i just
feel
and that's the crazy part i don't feel
bad sometimes i just feel great
but this impending feeling that's what i
want to get out of me
you know um
and i want to let you know too man um
that we recently got the website redone
theovonne.com
and you can check it out and
and uh and i'm sorry for just talking
about myself a lot on this episode i
really
am you know uh
but that you know
you know i you know it's funny because
sometimes i just have uh
i don't know
i think sometimes i i still have all
these these things inside me like i want
to say
you know but i just can't
i just don't know what they are
like i have this feeling sometimes like
there's like i want to say things in my
throat and i just don't know what they
are um
and sometimes i i think man well you're
just gonna keep talking to you figure it
out
you know and it's not gay stuff
either some people send me messages hey
fella
look at this weiner look at this thigh
thigh wiener
nut wiener nut nut and gay men need to
quit doing that
a lot of gay men sliding in there and in
the dms hey hey hey
you want to check out this weiner how
heavy is your wiener some guy asked me
how heavy
is your wiener get it together man
okay a lot of gay men take advantage of
the loophole of being gay
to make it that they can then be gross
towards straight men
and that is too much man send me a
message how heavy is your wiener
i'm not scaling my wiener man and i'm
not telling you
sir okay buddy it's you're being
nasty
so anyway i just had to say that
but what i'm telling you is we got the
website redone theovonne.com
and who did it was a company called
modify just finished the new site the
process
no joke was effortless that's what i
like
the turnaround was swift i don't have to
do anything it was almost like magic
it was almost like too good to be true
modify has a new plan that rivals any
other option
on the web market they provide a
subscription-based professional web
design service for the cost of your old
cable bill that's right
for just 249 dollars a month you will
enjoy the relief
of creating your new website easy
process quick turnaround
and an evergreen site and the
convenience of having a personal web
design team
assigned to your account to handle all
of your ongoing website needs
modify's plan includes unlimited updates
unlimited support
easy editing tools and and future
redesigns
no cost to build no contract and they do
it all for you
only 249 dollars a month get yours today
at modifymodiphy.com
theo that's modify modi m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com slash t-h-e-o
there's no f in modify these guys don't
f
around you feel me gang modify change
is good else can i tell you about man
um you know and i gotta recognize too
uh you know a lot of people are have are
feeling you know
rough it's so it's it's a rough time
there is a lot of you know we don't have
the regular things i was talking to uh
maurice clarett the other day
and man i really really admire that guy
he has so much solution in his in his
brain and in his heart and
and uh and
and he was saying you know one of the
reasons people are all so antsy right
now he thinks because
nobody has anything to do there's no
sports to watch there's no
outlet the only teams that have been
playing this whole time
have been political so everybody's
getting on one or the other
um so it's just it's interesting and i
thought about that people have become
more fans of politics
you know we've become more fan it's
become
without other sports and other things
politics has become the thing to be a
fan of
you know i like this quarterback i like
this quarterback oh the backup
quarterbacks
you know is racist the black the
the black up quarterback's racist you
know it's just there's all it just
there's people are becoming fans of
politics
and becoming activists that's one thing
i'm just do we've all i fee
i feel like we've all become such
addicts to all of this junk
that is then making us be
angry about stuff that i don't know if
we're really angry about
i know that we are concerned about
things
i know that we have views about things
but i don't know if we're really
angry about things
so i really question the the side effect
of
just all the snippets and all the
information in the constant barrage of
information
and the effect that has on us
you know it's just because you start to
wonder well everybody
like so many people are activists now
like what's going on
like i get being activated
but at some point it's just
we're i feel like
we're being taken advantage of you know
at some point we feel a little bit
used by all of the
just the media and all the hype and
and a lot of it's like panic porn you
know my brother's friend coined that
phrase and i don't know his last name
it's
i think he's a latino fella
but panic porn where you just
everybody's getting
some we're getting some some some
dopamine hit in our brain by getting off
on all of this uh
this political and social jack-jack
um and i made it up to black belt dang
dude i'm not sure i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so i
don't honestly
you know it's uh i mean what would riley
mouse say he don't know
that's what he would say bro so you got
to think about that sometimes or don't
think about it
and those are the options but yeah just
i just start to wonder well if i'm more
stressed out than usual there's more
what's going on what's causing me to
feel this way
um so
let's hear uh another call or two that
came in here we go
hey theo riley this is ray i'm from ohio
um but i live in a little town called
wheeling west virginia
oh yeah that wheeling feeling baby and i
got offered sex
by aunt and a niece one time over there
adults both both them adults adult sex
offer okay
and i know we've both had that wheeling
feeling
yep and that's pink eye also and um it's
a dangerous thing
you know if you if you hold on to that
feeling for too long you're gonna end up
doing some methamphetamines in the back
of a 7-eleven
amen baby hey that's a guarantee maybe
get
maybe get an ftv by the slurping machine
but um
i just wanted to call in say i'm a huge
fan um
you make my day a little better every
day i'm a coal miner
and i don't know that you've had any
coal miners call in
but um i wanted to say that uh it's a
tough job
it's a rewarding job um i just wanted to
say um
if there's any questions about coal
mining please reach out um
i'm a huge fan of the show thank you
thank you for everything
thank you brother i appreciate it and
maybe we do have maybe we do have a
question or two about coal mining
and if i think of what they are i'll let
you know
but right there you got to think about
that somebody going in the earth
and getting something out of the earth
helping it out
and that's really you know i'm not
trying to be racial here but that man
goes into the earth and gets something
black and helps it out of the earth
so that's pretty cool that's pretty
helpful
um you know it's
uh it's just pretty cool to see that you
go down there and you come up with a
bucket of black
a couple of paws a bucket of positive
black blacktivity
you know that coal baby and i love a
coal i love a briquette
and we actually had a black kid at our
school when i was growing up
uh briquette lawson
and he was beautiful actually he could
have been a male model actually but he
he just was he didn't he just he wasn't
doing all of that [ __ ] man he didn't
like a lot of [ __ ] like that
he liked more just regular [ __ ]
mcdonald's and [ __ ]
um let's take another call here we go
hey theo this is cole from texas
what and that guy's name is cold that's
baffling uh
that was totally unplanned there you go
and right there that's you see that wet
that wicked web that's out there onward
brother thank you cole
name after a briquette i'm just calling
see if i can maybe give you a little
encouragement i'm kind of in the same
boat as you
are i just moved to pursue a new career
and uh it's it's kind of nerve-wracking
really
you know i don't really know anybody
here and
i'm just trying to get into the group of
things in this new
uh foreign environment
but i hope you are doing well in your
new environment and that
you and your new buddy riley mal are
doing all right
alvin a good sound can't say i have
i've not well actually what is northeast
arkansas like what cities i mean you
know i'm a christian eagle scout i mean
you know i'm a christian i don't scout
well you know um thank you for that man
you know it is i just i have to remember
that because i wake up each day and
there's part
there's a question in my head like
why isn't everything perfect
you know there's like i'm not even
asking the question
there's some invisible thing in my head
every day that's asking this question
why isn't everything perfect why isn't
this done why isn't this done why isn't
this done
did you do this do you do this do you
and it just and it's like
i don't even hear it but i still it's
like it's like it was asked to me
decades ago and it still
echoes
so i think always when i wake up i
immediately just feel like oh
there's so much i haven't done there's
so much i have to do
there's not it's um
so i gotta recognize i gotta you know i
gotta recognize hey that that
that voice is not real
and while that voice will serve me well
sometimes to get to go and do some
things for myself and get me motivated
at some points that voice is just yeah
it's just it's just bothering me because
it's not going to give me any peace
um but man i'm sorry that you're
struggling with it man you know
some things i did do to state to stay
busy i joined the mma gym
i now have four bruised ribs some guy
named alex or alexis or something i
don't know what his name was
oh my god dude this guy he might have
eaten two of my ribs dude when i wasn't
looking this guy
did me he did me up um
so that is a lot of pain uh i went and
saw tim dillon perform
two times um
so that was really great i'm just trying
to get some new some some
guests onto the podcast trying to get
morgan wallin to come in i'm a
fan of his music he's a musician musical
man
uh we have a trucker next week coming in
female trucker
vaddrucker a lot of nate people will
call it
beautiful lady decent lady so
um
yeah so just just you know thanks for
thinking about me man
you know and i'm thinking about you
brother and i wish you well in that new
environment and just
yeah it's so funny man it's like i can
offer you suggestion but it's like i
can't hear it for myself
isn't that so crazy
it's fascinating man this thing that
we're part of
um all right let's hear another call
that came in here
uh and sorry to just keep going to calls
but
i just you know i want to get somebody i
just i'm just tired of listening to
myself sometimes
here we go hey theo
uh my name is chance
i'm from albuquerque new mexico and uh
i'm currently
about to i'm driving through amarillo
texas right now
i'm headed over to bentonville arkansas
for
a new job now bentonville arkansas home
of the largest
walmart and first walmart ever
so if you think about walmart think
about bentonville homework
for a sales job um and
i'm just kind of taking this huge leap
of faith i'm listening to some of your
podcasts and um
i just got the the urge to hit the
hotline you know i'm feeling a lot of
feelings right now
um and uh you know one of them is
that's really strong it's just uh just
hope
and hope for a better life hope for you
know
uh to be successful you know i said
i'm 23 and i and i haven't done much of
my life but i just got
got sober about almost three years ago
so my life has just been getting so big
and um you know i don't know maybe if
you have any advice for me you know
starting something new i know that you
traveled
you know you made a big change traveling
over to
california um and now you just made
another travel
you know down there to uh well thanks
for the call man and not to cut you off
uh but
but i did but um but yeah i uh
you know i think what you're doing
the the the long term of it is
you can't see it now but in the future
you'll see wow just by making
big by making moves it may it allows you
to
be less inhibited when you need to make
other moves
so in the future when an opportunity
comes up and in it
you know another move or an opportunity
to take a leap of faith and love or a
leap of faith in
in friendship or in a different realm
even
besides employment
that the experience you have had right
now
[Music]
you know that'll resonate within those
other fields and so you might
you won't even know you're like oh wow i
took a leap of faith here i took a leap
of faith there
um you know hell you can become a damn
long jumper
of faith if you leap enough man
i mean that sounds like what you're
doing so 23 you're trying a new city and
that's a lot man
you know and i need to be patient with
myself you know i get i get at home and
i it gets late and
you know just like you know my the place
is a mess and it's not even my place i'm
just renting it and
sometimes things just feel like heavy
man
and i just need to get some help i need
to when i need help if i need a
therapist if i need a
a house cleaner if i need a an assistant
if i need i just have to get
i gotta ask for what i need
you know i never you know i was talking
to my brother today and
man i never really asked for what i need
i never say hey this is what i need
i don't say it in relationships i don't
say it in friendships i don't put down
those
hey look this is what i need
because i don't want to be i don't want
to
you know i don't want to step on anytime
i don't want to
but it's funny i just won't put any you
know hey this this is what i need
you know i need sometimes i need someone
to listen to me and not even tell me
anything
you know the other day i was talking to
my brother and i was just telling him
i've been having a tough time and just
you know and i'm lucky my brothers
worked in like view therapy and stuff
like that and
um and at the end of the call he said
hey man i'll just
if you want i'll just sit on the line
with you for a little bit and
and not say anything
and at first i was like nah man i'm all
right you know
and when i said all right i could feel
something in my voice like i felt like i
wasn't all right
and he said it again he said no he said
look i'm happy to just sit here.
you know you don't have to say anything
and i don't have to say anything
um and i'll just be here with you
if you if you ne you know i can just be
here with you
and man i started bawling like
literally uncontrollably like a dragon
flew
out of my [ __ ] soul
because i think never in my life had
anybody just said hey i'll just
i'll be here with you
i'm not going to give you any suggest
i'm not going to give you any i'm not
going to give you any
i'm just i'm just going to be here for
you
if you need me
and it was powerful man it was and i i
just i had no idea in my whole life that
i how much i needed that
just even a mo i mean it was you know
and then you know i was like kind of
sobbing and
it's some you know some of this [ __ ] no
homo bruh some of the shit's kind of
you know it's tough to say i'm not
trying to sound like a little [ __ ] but
i'm trying to sound like
i don't get whatever dog if you're still
listening bro you par you
you part [ __ ] the same as i am son you
probably about 11
[ __ ] you feel me but um
and then i was like oh thanks man i'm
you know i'm good i kind of got my
composure
and then he said are you sure
and i s you know i lied i just said yeah
i'm good you know and i wasn't good i
didn't feel i just
and he goes i can still you know he said
i have like 10 minutes i can just sit
here with you
and man i just fell apart again
you know no i just
i don't know i think it just in just
such a world of so much sound and so
much constant constant constant
just like to for somebody to say that
they had 10 minutes
where they could just be there with me
man it was it was real powerful
because i think he was speaking to that
kid in me to that child you know that
young fellow who just
you know hey i can sit here with you
without any judgment without any
concern without it and not concerned
with with just concern
you know with just time
you know i can sit here and just
and just you just know the only thing
you need to know
is that i'm here for you
no matter what
and it was just powerful man um
so the hotline as always is 985-664-9503
uh i'll be back in with riley mao maybe
next week
we got that female trucker coming in i'm
excited about that
um we're also looking for a uh
if you know somebody who's who is a
unique
um death
person a death like a lifeguard but at a
funeral you know what i'm talking about
like a um
margin margin what is it a margin
a magician no
somebody that like you know hey hey hey
you know
here's the body you know that guy uh
like howie mandel but for like death
mortician
if you know somebody of a uh
a mortician do you not at all if you
know somebody that
is that is a decent or a unique
mortician
we would like to speak with them
you can email us i think through the
website or hit up uh
the real nick davis and you can let him
know
preferably around nashville or los
angeles
or within a flight distance you know
somewhere close
um but all right one last call that came
in here we go
i feel i just finished eating a
mcdonald's breakfast
griddle bacon sandwich
oh dang see you living high on the hog
today
literally onward little mama
and i really like them i started eating
them after i heard
a show on howard stern
and now it's one of my favorite things
to get in mcdonald's unfortunately we
can't get it after
10 30 a.m so my next favorite thing
at mcdonald's is the slay of fish but i
always want
lettuce and onion on that sandwich
um so my question is
what's your favorite fast food spot
well i can't ma'am i love you hey i'm
gonna tell you that straight up
and i'm here for you
and i won't say anything but i do have
to i can't handle if you can't eat a
damn filet of fish in a mcdonald's
you can't eat a filet of fish at a
mcdonald's mama
that ain't even fish in there
you know that's trans oyster or
something they're using her
you know they're not using fish meat
that ain't damn
fish meat uh
you know they're you know that's
something else
they're doing something nasty nasty
you can't be having a you know i can't
if i'm trying to talk to a lady and she
have a bite of
filet of fish on her lip
come on you kid your children can't even
love you if you're sitting around with a
bite of fillet of
fish on your mouth on your breath
who do you love people can't love you
if you eating filet of fishes lady they
can't love you
[Music]
and they can but it's just it's gonna be
harder
it's so hard to level one when you see
her with it you know you go in her car
and she gots a couple
you know you open up to get the glove
compartment thing to get a lozenge or
something for
and a damn filet of fish rapper freaking
rolls out
like a dang tumbleweed just
[Music]
it's hard to love somebody that's on
them filet of fishes baby you know that
and if you don't you get then you know
it now
um
okay i think we got it we had some calls
that came in about riley mao but we'll
we'll get to them next week you know we
just had him here this week just in
spirits i mean you know i'm a christian
um you know and he's a talented man
um so
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
we don't have to figure it all out today
that's what i got to remind myself
is we don't have to figure it all out
today and we don't have to figure it all
out alone
and you know i feel a little bit better
than when this
then when this episode started
you know i'm gonna even see if my dang
therapist emailed me back i'll check
right now
nope not yet
but there's an a meeting in five minutes
online then i can jump in
and as much as i don't want to i want to
go do something else i want to do i want
to you know do my bookie bet on a
night game i want to do this i want to
do that
you know it's probably what i need to do
for myself
you know i got to get active in taking
care of how i feel
instead of just
just being reactive to it all the time
you know if i'm going to feel this much
as i do i deserve to have some control
over it
so anyway thank you guys for coming out
there in new jersey both shows were
great i just felt like the early one was
more tame
the second one when people was drunk
people was out there drinking each
other's blood
you know somebody's out there they had
some guy came out with a uh
you know we had another guy that came
out i guess he had a fake
hand or something he lost a hand you
know he lost a hand he uh
you know some guy he was maybe he was
you know throwing dice
you know and mowing the yard at the same
time and and
you know and he caught a blade uh but
he left his hand there some guy
so that's wild you know you go home and
you can't even
you know i guess he drove home just with
you know instead of ten and two just ten
maybe just locked in at ten or something
unless he just taped his arm to the
wheel on the other side at two
but that's you know some guy woke up but
he don't know where his hand is at
you know when they got a bucket of beers
five empty beers and a damn
cold hand in there so if that's you man
call uh blue grotto
b-l-u-g-r-o-t-t-o over there about a dog
park
and you guys too i want to say shout out
to uh
to joey diaz
and his new podcast
you guys got to go check it out it's
just starting up uncle joey's
joint and it's uh you know
i watched some of it and it made me feel
good to just kind of share what was
going on
you know sometimes i like to be
entertaining and sometimes i just
i just want to be and um
and i know you guys don't you know i i
just it gets in my head as to what's
going on but uh
but you guys have always been there for
me man and i just appreciate it
you know and i love you
um and i love the groupie
you know i got to meet some of you here
and there out in jersey couple quick
groups and this and that and
man i was walking you know i was so ha
i was so happy that i didn't drink like
because i just because i'm trying not to
i'm not saying there's anything bad if
you look if you're doing some good coke
i'll hold the back of your neck you know
while you do it bro you know what i'm
saying i'll feel your tits while you do
a little coke
that's who i am bro even if you're a man
bruh brought you a strong man
but um
but i'm walking from the from the
venue they had a like a bouncer guy that
would walk you to the back of the stage
[Music]
and he we just started talking he's like
yeah man i got 23 years sobriety and i
was like damn
and it was just exciting you know and he
said his dad had a couple years of
sobriety and
and it was just nice because in that
moment i was you know
i was towing my line whatever my line
was you know and i was it was just
like oh okay good i'm glad i'm here for
this just to be here with this moment
because then i could connect with him i
said oh man i'm
i have six months and almost drank today
and i'm just
man it's just really hard right now uh
and so yeah in that moment there was
somebody i could tell that to
uh because you go just run up to a
random stranger at the show and
you tell them that well actually a lot
of the people that come to our show is
pretty good
but he might be like oh dude well
where's have you seen my hand like no
you lost your hand dude that's crazy
[ __ ]
you only be able to hitchhike in one
direction now dude
um let's go out the way we came in man
naked and feet first no
uh let's go out the way we came in
[Music]
this is spencer sorry
maybe just you
but i've been working hard as i can
just find some time
it's time to get you all alone so
we can we can we going out on the city
[Applause]
[Music]
um
oh
we going
come on let's go baby i'm taking you out
baby you know
you're so pretty so pretty baby i don't
have a plan b
[Music]
i don't need a plan b you my baby
that is grady spencer and the work
if you're taking your lady out play that
song for him on the way out when you're
leaving the house you're getting ready
put that on
put that on for him this is our time you
know
you're gonna enjoy it i know some
couples came out and
and sat at the table the other night it
was cold at that second show too
and uh and just thank you guys man
just thank you for being a part of my
life man and let me be a part of yours
and
i'm excited about where we're heading uh
and i'm just trying to take care of
myself while we get there baby gang